Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my full
Marvel Secret Invasion Episode 4 Video.
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references.
couple big twist
confirming some of our theories.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'm doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
We're also doing a giveaway for Disney
plus memberships.
all you have to do to enter.
Be a subscriber
and just post all your theories
for the last two episodes
how they'll finally pay this off.
careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
we'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through, shop by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
mostly R.I.P.
Talos and confirming Skrull, Rhodey.
Most people on the comments
want to call him grody, but technically
it's a female Skrull,
so you can think of that any way you want.
But starting with the episode title
Beloved, a reference to Nick Fury's wife
and her favorite poem, Late Fragment
by Raymond Carver,
which they use as a metaphor
in the episode across the timeline,
like in the flashbacks and in present day
for how she's found happiness loving
Nick Fury and being Nick Fury's beloved
the whole idea that she understands that
Nick Fury did love her this whole time.
And he also admits to that later.
Like, even if I could do it again, like,
even if I had a time travel device
like the Avengers endgame,
it could actually travel back in time
and do this all again.
I would do things the same way
and still be with this woman.
this is also probably going
to be the shortest episode by far
without the credits.
It was about 30 minutes long,
which is closer to the run of like
wandavision or She-Hulk episodes,
which had much longer episode runs,
but shorter actual episodes.
the reason why Marvel does
that is just because of overall budget.
Like they tried to spend about $150
million per series, so they had to break
that $150 million into either six longer
episodes or nine shorter episodes.
that is the only reason why you don't have
like nine episodes or ten episodes
or 13 episodes that are all like
45 minutes long, like a typical HBO show.
the first time
that's probably going to change
will be Daredevil Born Again,
because they're 18 episodes
that they've already greenlit for that
they'll be shooting.
It'll be all of season one.
There's no way they can do 18 episodes.
Even if they're shorter for $150 million,
they do spend way more money on that.
actual opening scene, though,
just picks up right at the end of last
week's episode
with G'iah dead on the ground
after being shot by Gravic confirming
my theory that they would just open up
with the scene of her healing, the damage
with the new Extremis super abilities,
then flashing back to explain how
she gave herself super small abilities,
even if you didn't predict
how this was going to go down,
I feel like they telegraphed it
because she's in all this trailer footage
that hasn't appeared in episodes yet
mean that she'd be in episode
5 and Episode 6.
So we knew that she was still alive.
Somehow all.
Explain why.
Two Because they have a conversation later
in Taylor's
death at the end of the episode,
I think it's meant to catalyze her
and she's eventually going to take
Taylor's place as Nick Fury's right
hand person,
like the Abigail brand of the MCU.
the actual intros pretty quick.
Like they tell you what happened to G'iah,
how she gave herself powers
that she was escaping pretty quickly.
Then jump to the regular opening credits
aren't any different
then they flashback again
to tell you more.
Nick Fury BackStory in Paris
during 2012, right
after the events of the first Avengers
movie meeting with his wife,
they referenced the events of the Avengers
movie in The Battle of New York.
In the paper
in one of the big surprises here
is that apparently he didn't tell his wife
about The Avengers
at all, even as a concept
before he put them together.
remember, he'd started creating the idea
for The Avengers, like the document
back in 1995, right
after the events of the Captain
Marvel movie, before he met her,
So during their entire relationship,
like 17 years later, never once
had he told her
anything about The Avengers,
which is a good example of how deeply
he keeps secrets, even from his wife,
just how compartmentalized
his life is like.
They made him seem that way
during Captain America Winter Soldier,
all the other Avengers movies
like The last time
I trusted someone, I lost
and I got taken out by Goose the Falcon.
Meaning he no longer trusts anyone.
But the funny thing that's going on with
this is that he's keeping his wife
in the skrulls in general secret
from The Avengers and Shield on one side,
but also now keeping the Avengers
themselves secret from all the Skrulls
and his wife.
But it's generally meant to be happy
meeting that they're having a celebratory
dinner just meeting together, chilling out
after the events of the Avengers.
Like, okay, the world has been saved,
we can just have dinner together
and be a couple for a little while.
the set of the whole bit
with the Raymond Carver poem
Late Fragment,
about her wanting to be beloved on Earth.
The whole idea of their relationship,
like a metaphor
for their entire relationship.
can also see all the Earth references
in that poem are also a callback to
the secret invasion plot with the Skrulls
looking for a home on earth.
I think eventually
they also want to use the poem
as a metaphor for Nick Fury and Taylor's
relationship too.
And it's the same vibe with them as well.
They're both happier having been friends,
obviously now in memoriam to Taylor's
made reference that in previous episodes
to where Taylor's basically
told him outright, You're much better off
having known us the Skrulls.
Look at what we did for you.
proving that a lot of Nick Fury successes
over the years,
all the things he accomplished were done
so on the backs of the Skrulls
when Nick Fury says
he's more of a history guy,
that's a reference to Captain America
in World War Two and also a reference
to comic book Nick Fury history being part
of the actual Howling Commandos himself
in fighting with Captain America
during actual World War Two.
This time she is wearing her ring on her
ring finger, meaning that they've long
since been married.
There is exactly when they got married.
But sometime after 1997,
Then they jump forward to present day
with her meeting Skrull Rhodey
in the church, paying off the conversation
they had on the phone
from last week's episode.
she'd been trying to contact Braddock,
but this Skrull, pretending to be
Rhodey,
is the one managing all that conversation.
And She knows
this is a Skrull pretending to be Rhodey.
But they make a bunch of jokes
about firing
Nick Fury in a bunch of wrestling jokes
as well.
Going
full undertaker on him from the top rope,
proving that this Skrull
is a big wrestling fan.
They made jokes about this
during the Thor movies with the Asgardians
on Earth becoming fans of Earth culture
like Thor becomes fans of video games.
So apparently this Skrull
just became a fan of wrestling.
They also make
it sound like President Ritson is an idiot
when she talks about what Gravic needs
or wants her to do.
Now they make it sound like she's
been working with Gravic for a while.
They reference that
in previous episodes too.
I think that started back up
after the five year time jump
like after Avengers
Infinity War in the snap,
she started working with the Skrulls
again.
The big surprise, though, was
when they did pull the guns on each other
but refusing to shoot each other
all explained that in the second to
they revealed that Nick Fury low
jacked her so that he could listen in on
their conversation.
Although she sounds like
she kind of knew it was happening
because she was a shield agent
for a long time.
Secretly is a Skrull, but still a shield
agent for Nick Fury going out on mission
so she'd be just as smart
as they like Black Widow
or any of the other people
that had those skills.
But the idea is that she loves Nick Fury
and she wasn't going to kill him,
so she just let him do that.
even during their conversation,
she knew that Nick Fury knew
what she had just been doing with Skrull.
Rhodey
there are couple of funny
Nick Fury reactions, though,
while he's
listening in on their conversation.
Like he seems completely unperturbed.
Like, Yep, this is definitely Skrull.
Rhodey Like he suspects him
because in their previous conversation
he called him Nick
and nobody calls him Nick.
so at least for the past
couple of episodes, it sounds like Nick
Fury has known that he wasn't Skrull.
the only thing
that gets a reaction out of him
is that funny moment where his wife is
like, you don't need to kill him.
He's an old man. He's
so feeble, he'll die on his own.
He'll probably even die pretty soon.
like he's a little pissed at people
thinking that he's a potentially weak
old man. Like, I'm not old. I'm not weak.
school.
Rhodey clearly doesn't take the bait
and basically says
that he's going to kill Priscilla or Vera,
however you want to think about her
if she doesn't kill Nick Fury.
And he's also going to kill Nick Fury
either way, like either you kill him
or I'll kill you and kill him.
So if you weren't on the fence
about Rhodey being a squirrel,
I feel like their conversation during
this moment here is meant to confirm that
They do have the shower a moment later
in the episode, like, very spicy
shower moment, revealing
that it is a Skrull turning into Rhodey.
but I feel like that was just
for the really thick people
that weren't watching very closely.
most of us felt like Rhodey was probably
a Skrull several episodes ago.
Gravic sets out to kill the president,
making the United States
think that it's the Russians.
But he also doesn't realize
the guy is a Super Skrull like him now.
So he thinks that she's dead and gone.
So that'll be a big surprise for him.
Later in episode five, Speaking of which,
we then jump to Emilia Clarke's G'iah,
who has this look on her face
when she's meeting with Talos,
but she's super pissed off at grabbing
and just kind of shaken
based on what's happened.
Like she didn't totally understand
how the super cool powers would work,
but she had an idea.
but the idea is that she's fully on Team
Talos and Nick Fury now
on the condition
that they finally figure out what to do
with the rest of the swarms.
Like you finally need
to find us a place to live,
be it Earth or be it somewhere else.
lot of people think that they should
just go to Thanos Garden Planet,
which is a surprise that they wouldn't
just go there because The Avengers
didn't destroy that.
Like even all the time travel
they executed
didn't change the fact
that that was a garden planet.
my assumption right now is that they don't
just take them right there
or they didn't take them right there
because some other species took it over
When Talos apologizes
for forcing her into this, quote unquote,
he's talking about inducting her into Nick
Fury's covert Skrull team,
thinking that that's what ultimately led
to her siding with grabbing all the time
that she spent working in these undercover
operations based on her age.
I'd say that she was working for Nick Fury
before the events of Captain America
Winter Soldier in the demise of Shield.
So she'd been going out on missions for
him doing stuff like this for a long time.
but just based on the plans
Marvel is making for Phase five and phase
six and where things are going
in the story for the Skrulls,
it seems pretty obvious
that they're going to stay on earth
like those million skrulls
most of them will stay on earth.
And even though Marvel Phase five
is kind of like the dark rain
era of Marvel, like things will get worse
before they get better.
Obviously Thunderbolt
Ross is going to become the next U.S.
president by Captain America for The idea
is that slowly over years,
the Earth will just slowly grow
to accept the skrulls
the same way that they're accepting Thor
in the Asgardians.
Like, how could they accept the asgardians
a bunch of aliens living on earth,
but not the Skrulls The main reason for
that is because the Asgardians
have been living on Earth
for several years now since the snap it.
Also in their natural form,
they look just like humans,
like they don't look that different.
so most people around the earth aren't
xenophobic of them Also, they saw Thor
being a hero through all of the Avengers
movies Saving Planet Earth.
they've seen the benefit
of having as guardians on Earth
and they're very accepting of them in
that way.
Tails is trying to tell G'iah that he's
trying to do the same thing for them.
Like we need to save the U.S.
president, like his whole bid
is to save the president
and prove to the rest of the planet
that some of them are good
and they can enrich the earth
with their culture and their technology.
the problem, though, is that
in their natural form, they look boring.
They look very not human.
smoothing right now,
like before things spin up into dark rain
of Marvel Phase five,
the Earth is probably 5050.
Like half the Earth would be okay
with the Skrulls eventually,
and then the other half
wants to kill them at first sight.
not in my backyard Skrulls.
Marvel has also been doing a lot of viral
marketing for Secret Invasion.
Just having Skrulls
walk through the background
of regular news broadcasts in theme parks,
which are doing the regular stuff
that you would see out in present day.
I think ultimately that's where things
are headed at the end of secret invasion,
like the world
will learn the truth of the Skrulls,
that the million Skrulls living on Earth
and you just start seeing Skrulls
popping up all over the place
through future Marvel movies.
nobody is special.
Just like totally normal Skrulls,
living their normal lives.
but part of the idea is that Talos
sacrificed his life.
The president will learn that
and he will tell the world about.
Like this Skrull died to save my life.
The Skrulls can be good.
People ultimately paying off
Talus is speech with his daughter.
but when he also talks about
showing the people of Earth their hearts
like we need to show them who we are.
I think the G'iah will ultimately be
the person to pay that Emilia Clarke's
character by the end of the series,
using her father's death as motivation.
talking more
about the consequences of this, though.
Like,
how do we get to President Thunderbolt?
Ross I think the idea is that he survives
this, the president survives this.
either there's a reelection
in the next year or two and he loses
the reelection or his injuries are so bad
that he has to leave office.
The vice president has to take over
in that eventually the vice president
loses a reelection in Thunderbolt.
Ross winds up
winning on the platform of safety
and security like they'll trade
on the fear from secret invasion.
Like, look how close the skrulls came
to taking over our planet.
There are million of them everywhere.
Be afraid they could be anywhere.
in a sort of thunderbolt Ross
pulling a Thanos like moment
where he's like, Fine, I'll do it myself.
Only this time
it's on planet Earth in the United States,
paving the way for him to give himself
red hole powers, allowing the world
to take over the weapons.
Plus program, create
the sentry, do all kinds of crazy stuff
throughout Marvel Phase
five into Marvel, Phase six.
before his wife goes back to their house
and he tells her basically the same thing
that she told him back in 2012
during the flashback that he's loved her
and happy
that they've been together all these years
like I said earlier in the video,
she explains the full backstory
of why she chose Priscilla's face
and her identity back in the nineties.
the woman she got the identity
and the face from was named Dr.
Priscilla Davis,
who died of a congenital heart defect.
Bora worked at the hospital
Priscilla was in
and got to know her that way
because she was on a secret mission
for the Skrulls to try and find a way
to work against Nick very
to have something against him
if they needed it.
she was going to find someone's face,
someone's identity
that she could pretend to be that Nick
very would fall in love with,
and they would use that against him
should they ever need to.
before the real Priscilla died, though,
Vera told her the truth about the Skrulls
and asked her permission
to use her identity on the condition
that she be buried at sea,
that she would continue
to keep up appearances
for Priscilla's parents so they wouldn't
learn the real Priscilla died
and that she would never hurt Nick Fury.
so even though the Skrulls
were playing a long game
against Nick Fury back in the nineties,
you remember she'd already started her
relationship with Nick Fury
and then chose Priscilla Space.
That's why
when they met each other in the nineties,
he was like,
Oh, where did you get this face from?
But it already seen like
they'd been together for a little while.
but in present day, it's basically her
telling Nick Fury that she was not going
to follow through with Gravic
and Roddy's orders to kill him.
Meaning now,
Rhodey and Gravic want her dead as well.
But in the later
trailer footage from future episodes
we saw fighting with Guy is character.
So we knew that she was going to be on
Team Nick Fury anyway.
that if you were confused
why they still both picked up their guns
and both shot at each other
at the same time,
that's just
because both are meant to be wary,
untrusting people like it's kind of a joke
about how Nick Fury doesn't
trust anyone, even though he does admit
to loving his wife.
There's just a little bit inside
each of them
that isn't sure that each other person
is secretly one of Gravic's skrulls
pretending to be that person
the reason why they purposefully miss
and then
laugh at each other at their reaction
is because Nick Fury, for example,
still wouldn't be able to kill his wife
if she were trying to kill him.
That's how much he loves her
And when she says, Don't worry about me,
I can take care of myself.
That's just a callback to her
being a shield agent,
even though she was kind of a shield
agent on the deal
we get that red hot, spicy shower scene
revealing that is Skrull Rhodey
But the Skrull pretending to be him
is a female.
It doesn't really matter
like Skrulls do have gender.
There are female and male skrulls
But they can pretend to be whatever
organic life they want to.
It doesn't matter.
back in earlier
episodes, Talos pretended to be a woman.
for all the regular skrulls that aren't
super skrulls I think the limitation
on their shapeshifting ability
is sort of a conservation of mass idea,
like they can make themselves
bigger or shorter, but they have to have
the same amount of mass relatively
so they made themselves way bigger.
They'd be way weaker.
but when it comes to the super skrulls,
all bets are off
just because they all have those
special powers Nick very surprises Skrull
Rhodey saying that his favorite booze is
Pappy Van Winkles Bourbon I believe.
I think it's bourbon
the nanotech joke is a reference to him
being war machine in all the Iron
Man's stark tech armor,
wondering if we're ever going
to see a version of Rhodey
during this series in the War
Machine Armor.
a lot of people also asking
what's going on with the real Rhodey?
Because we know that he's going to be
in the Iron Man Armor Wars
movie during Marvel Phase six,
but it'll be the real Rhodey by that time.
We'll probably get answers about what
Gravic did with the real Rhodey
by the end of this series,
They'd have to be keeping him alive
somewhere, secretly,
right now, I think the best theory about
when it became Skrull.
Rhodey like when the Skrull took
his place is back
when he was injured during Captain America
Civil War in the hospital
but the whole idea here is
it's all just meant to be a play
to get him to drink the bourbon
which has the liquid tracker in it.
he knows Rhodey has a Skrull
and pretty much says that to his face.
But Rhodey says they'll reveal the footage
of him killing Maria Hill.
Even though it's Gravic,
pretending to be Nick Fury,
nobody would believe Nick Fury
that it's not really him.
during the president's convoy,
when he makes the Lenin quote
about stopping, when you find steel,
that's
also another reference to Rhodey
being war machine, as the president here
should stop before he gets into the car
because bad things are going to happen.
Like he's taunting the president, knowing
that they're about to try and kill him.
Shortly.
they also make it seem like Skrull.
Rhodey drank
the rest of that entire bottle of bourbon,
like the schools have really high
tolerance, but the smell still lingers.
So he reeks of bourbon.
Gravic's skrulls attacked the convoy.
The reason why they all speak in Russian
on the comms is so that the Secret Service
will pick up their transmissions
in Russian and see the Russian uniforms
thinking that it really is
the Russians attacking them,
trying to set off World War three.
noticed during the attack.
Skrull, Rhodey just sitting there,
totally unperturbed in the car, like,
All right, let's get on with this.
Kill the president,
move on to the next thing.
Gravic uses his Super Skrull abilities.
This time it's the group powers
to reach out and grab and crush them.
Secret Service agents remember,
every time they become super skrulls,
they get all the abilities
that they already have.
The only one we haven't seen so far
is them using call Obsidian Hand.
Maybe they'll get that in episode five.
And it seems like they can just graft
on extra powers ad nauseum, so there's
no limit to the amount of powers
they can give each other, so both Gravic
some of the other skrulls Emilia Clarke's
character have a couple of powers
they can get even more in the future.
the part of the reference, though, is
even though they're using
all these different MCU
characters, all the different powers
are meant to represent the original comic
book powers of the super Skrull, which
were based on the Fantastic Four's powers.
the reason why
they have to use the work around here,
why they can't just be legit Fantastic
four powers is because they haven't
actually introduced the MCU version
of the team yet, we'll probably find out
who's actually going to play those MCU.
Fantastic
Four characters pretty soon though.
But the writers strike,
they have the actors strike.
That might happen this week.
So they're just like a bunch of stuff
that Hollywood is waiting for before
they make a bunch of big announcements.
Taylor's gets hit and reverts to his
Skrull form helping to save the president
while Nick Fury tries to fight off,
grabbing in sight of the Secret Service.
So they see him
trying to save the president, Hopefully.
Taylor's was correct when he was telling
his daughter that his play would work.
saving the president's
life would help win them asylum on Earth.
he's didn't expect to die in the process.
Gravic then kills him.
I think they want to make it
pretty obvious that he kills them.
Nick Fury, then tries to kill him,
shooting him a couple of times.
Learning about his super skill
abilities in the extreme is healing.
So R.I.P.
Taylor's press F to pay respects for him.
Nick was forced to leave him behind
in order to finish saving the president,
what they'll probably do
is that next week in episode five,
they'll begin immediately after this.
In the aftermath with Nick Fury
at the hospital with the president,
and then meeting with Taylor's
daughter, G'iah, Emilia Clarke's character,
to figure out what they're going to do
next and for her to mourn her father.
Like I said, though, Taylor's dying,
I think, is meant to pave the way for
Emilia Clark's character to take his place
as Nick Fury's right hand person
running the saber space station
like Abigail Brand does in the comics.
I don't think she's supposed to be
in the Marvel's movie, though.
We'll see about that.
But I do think they do have a lot of plans
for her in the future,
the same way that they want to bring back
Kate Carrington's Black Knight character
to make more Game of Thrones references.
Game of Thrones actor
showing up in the Marvel Universe.
speaking of which, Kit Harington and Amy
Clarke just had a reunion at a convention
recently talking a lot about their time
on Game of Thrones,
talking about their Marvel characters,
even though they haven't met on screen
as Marvel characters yet.
right now, my expectation for Kit
Harington's Black Knight coming back.
Originally, I think it was supposed
to be The Blade movie,
but then they completely changed
what was going to be happening
in that movie in the time period
it was going to take place in.
And I think they'll bring him back
either during Avengers five, Qing Dynasty
or Avengers six Secret Wars, after
that, all bets are off, but they can do
a ton of stuff with his character.
it was a pretty quick episode,
but if there are any Easter eggs
or references that you spotted
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments
by episode
five Trailer video we'll post Thursday,
My full Episode five video.
We'll post next week
after they release it.
there was a bunch of stuff
that also just happened
the last couple of days.
There was a brand new Deadpool
three video of Wolverine versus Deadpool.
I'll try to do a video for that
in the next couple of days, really soon.
There was a new Blue Beetle trailer video,
so I'll do a video for that.
And James Gunn also just announced
what a couple of his new Justice League
characters would be in Superman Legacy.
So more videos for all that stuff
posting in the next couple of days.
even though Marvel isn't doing
a big Comic-Con panel on Hall
H, like there's not a whole lot of whole
H stuff on this year at Comic-Con from DC,
from Marvel, even from Sony Marvel stuff
like the Spider-Man related stuff.
think the idea is that everybody's
dropping a bunch of trailers
just outside of Comic-Con,
so we'll still get
a bunch of really big stuff
the next couple of weeks.
click here for that brand new Deadpool
three video
and click here for my secret Invasion
Episode 5 Video.
Update the links as soon as I post
both of those.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!